et les quinze fois par jour au téléphone
c'est jeudi c'est bien plus que mon
patron pour moi quand je vois des gens
qui disent oui le patron de cevital ya
franchement je vous jure que c'est
franck le patron parce que je l'appelle
très souvent pour avoir son avis et il a
un très bon regard asha catari la dei
des lilas et le conte parfois trop
d'idées non mais 16
oui on sait on des faits voilà je suis
très bien que la copie d'hier ne sera
pas la copie de rentrer à l'elysée un
plaisir voilà c'est factuel sa demande
de la famille de normes au nikon hausse
[Rires]
par rapport à moi qui ai vraiment ça
cette année syrie va faire je crois
beaucoup de prime jeudi avant btp
notamment il y aura voilà il ya beaucoup
de prades la narguer le moine et tout ça
est ce que cette année à la maxime on a
eu toute la question est sérieuse
est ce que cette année il y aura des
prime pour certains chroniqueurs ou des
problèmes autres que cyril ou même que
oui que si elle comme il a pu le moine
voilà h2o autre que cyril alors il y
aura forcément des prime tout le monde
parce que je ne pense pas que cyril
passe des prime tous les jeudis on a une
case entièrement dédié h2o donc avec un
prime divertissement et le retour de btp
il n'est pas voilà ce que je pense que
si elle n'a pas l'intention de faire
tous les prime il prendra la case une
fois de temps en temps de façon
événementielle
après bien évidemment il va avoir une
rotation encore une fois en tant hanouna
on est mi juin en fin août
j'ai cette année n'ont pas de quoi pas
de personnes d'animateurs comprends pas
esi n'ont rien mais c'est bon j'ai fini
ma question et même marquer là bas non
vie vous ne regardiez pas de personnes
âgées parce que chaque année on est
quelqu'un qui est arrivé sabatier lagaf
williams qui sont arrivés qui je sais
quoi c'est qui le vieux dr si kelly
[Rires]
il ya une époque où les annonceurs
étaient partis s qui sont revenus et en
masse autour de l'émission tv quasi tous
les annonceurs sont revenus sur sur la
chaîne en général mais aussi sur tb
l'idée puisque je pense que c'est le
sens de ta question oui à aucun aucun
problème et il y en a peut-être deux qui
ne sont parvenus mais c'est pas ce
qu'ils demandent contrex sur le saut
franck chirez nous annoncer qu'il allait
faire un one man show
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur
justement qu'ils abandonnent un peu la
télé pour faire pour avoir d'autres
aventures peut-être plus grisantes pour
lui la scène patrons de chaînes je sais
pas je pense que s'il ya un sens de
l'organisation pour lui qui fait que non
mais franchement
d'abord je pense que c'est 8 va
l'accompagner dans cette aventure va
aussi créer l'événement autour de ça
donc je l'achète va s'investir
massivement là dedans et non me
connesson planning façon c'est quand
même dans les quotidiennes celles qui
s'arrête le moins longtemps dans l'année
vous le savez belle idée qu'il allait
voir les gens il ya plein de gens qui
peuvent pas venir ici dans le public
c'est bien qu'ils nous sommes
entièrement d'accord
merci raymond franck tant d'amour
détenus nous voir mais franchement il
vous a régalé et tu sais que je t'aime
et là des prix
[Applaudissements]